[Música]
[Aplausos]
y seguimos con nuestras entrevistas en
directo américa de frança 24 en el marco
de la feria internacional del libro en
la ciudad de bogotá y hoy me acompaña
cristian cuello él es un escritor
español vamos a hablar del libro hombres
a los que bese cristian yo siento que ya
te conozco de toda la vida porque antes
de que hicieran todo lo puede poner las
cámaras al uso para acceder entrevista
pues conversamos hasta lo que no nos dio
sabes que yo siento que ya somos amigos
a 20 minutos es increíble la de cosas
que se pueden hacer en 20 minutos raúl y
entre ellas esto que habéis montado aquí
en un momento que sinceramente tengo que
dar las gracias por esto y por el
espacio a la poesía no gracias a ti por
favor cristian por estar con nosotros
por acompañarnos bueno una conversación
entre amigo entonces de qué se trata tu
libro pues el libro trata que te va a
parecer una obviedad pero de los hombres
a los que he besado
es mentira en realidad he besado a
bastantes más incluso mujeres pero ocho
han sido las relaciones que he tenido
vale y hombres a los que vez en acción
la pandemia en este momento en que se
cerraban las puertas se cubrían las
bocas se deshacían los abrazos y yo dije
ostras me queda un solo con dos gatos en
una soledad obligada y pensé he tenido
ocho relaciones ocho hombres igual lo
que no funcionaba no era tanto algo de
ellos sino algo que tengo yo dentro y
esto yo creo que era me gusta la
infancia hasta que me atormenta y fue
darme cuenta de esto no de que soy un
poco todos los hombres a los que ves
algo que tanto te atormenta pues pues me
atormenta muchas cosas sobre todo porque
cuando te dan un bofetón y te dicen que
es una caricia crees que es amor y
entonces eso es muy peligroso entonces
todo empieza desde la infancia y como
este libro y como cualquier historia que
cuentes de amor de desilusión de
esperanza de todo empieza por lo que
eres y al final somos un cúmulo de
nuestras traumas de la infancia qué
quiere decir a esos hombres en el libro
depende de cuál porque claro hay muchas
y hay ocho no necesita entonces no pero
hay historias de todo tipo no está el
primer amor está el amor que dices cómo
pude permitirme esto no me perdono a mí
mismo no haber hecho esto también hay el
amor que dices me equivoqué de digerir y
sinceramente ha sido lo mejor que me ha
pasado pero también está el amor de el
hombre y cuando me refiero al hombre me
refiero al padre también no el beso que
te da tu padre o incluso que no te da
que también es un beso cristian es
tienes cuatro libros de poesía y también
dos novelas digamos cuál es la
diferencia de escribir poesía o de
escribir una novela que no sea poesía
evidentemente pues todo el género para
empezar un poemario no te puedes obligar
tú no puedes decir voy a escribir horas
al día para hacer un poemario porque
esto es mucho más visceral no es una
construcción no como puede ser una
novela en el que tienes que desarrollar
una trama y tienes que realizar una
evolución de personajes no contar la
historia al final que quieres contar y
sobre todo que quede un mensaje al final
la poesía yo creo que es como el rayito
de luz que te descubre la herida no es
un diagnóstico y viene muy dentro de lo
que te atraviesa no es muy diferente en
una novela y para mí ambos géneros son
necesarios y vitales a la hora de
expresarme lo estábamos hablando te
puede ser cristian somos amigos no por
supuesto cristo estábamos hablando
anteriormente y la poesía yo te decía
que para mí a lo mejor no sé tú ti
también quiero que lo conversamos con
televidentes era como que lo más real lo
más puro que puede tener un escritor
porque es sale como una inspiración en
cambio una novela también como lo
estábamos diciendo es algo que bueno ya
tú tienes que sentarte más estructurado
pensar más para ti que cómo empezó tu
amor con con la poesía empezaste
escribiendo poesía empezarás tejiendo
otro tipo de literatura bueno yo empecé
leyendo que yo creo que es la gimnasia
de la escritura y yo creo que es al
final lo que lo que te hace es como a
cualquiera que le gusta algo no yo
pensaba de pequeño ojalá perdón
ojalá hubiese escritorio peterpan no
entonces yo que cuando fuese mayor
quería escribir peterpan y de repente
hizo una cosa que se llama el chico las
estrellas pero no es un chico que volaba
era un chico que era gay es mi vida
entonces de repente yo empecé a escribir
leyendo en realidad no no me di cuenta
pero yo cuando estaba leyendo y no solo
peter pan o te comentaba antes a
benedetti a benjamín prado al bid a
sastre a gloria fuertes cuando usa
poetas que en tres versos a mí me leían
la vida y entonces yo quería hacer
crecer es una trampa lo dices porque es
una trampa te parece que la vida es una
trampa no crecer lo es porque porque
resbala por una rampa y te obligan a
crecer y no tienes otra opción y porque
hay que es una trampa en la que hay que
caer vale explico cuando crecemos al
final estamos jugando a vivir y jugar a
vivir es una movida en realidad muy
grande vale porque empiezan las
tristezas las desesperanzas empiezas a
conocer las cosas y yo creo que cuanto
más conoces cuanto menos niño eres más
puedes decepcionarte porque es la
realidad no por eso yo creo que la
fantasía juega un papel fundamental
cuando somos niños pero también deberías
seguir jugándolo cuando somos adultos
por eso crecer es una trampa porque
estás diciendo lo que estás diciendo que
no a una parte fundamental para soportar
la realidad infancia amor tensiones en
el paseo por todo tu libro los hombres
de los que desee cuando llegas la
redención pues al final del libro y en
cada momento de mi vida porque todos los
días yo me pregunto en plan de o igual a
quilá el iad o no sé si perdonar menos
así y te diré más no me he redimido de
todo esto esta es la verdad no yo creo
que estas son además es que te agradezco
de que haya dicho estas tres palabras
precisamente porque definen el libro
estos son mis tres secretos guardarlos
como amuletos crecer besar y perdonar
infancia amor y redención este libro una
catarsis para ti te sirvió de desahogar
de llenar muchas cosas que tenías que el
amor es difícil no también obviamente
expresar o hablar con alguien así será
con un terapeuta lo que sea de los
sentimientos tan profundos que tiene uno
y qué rico escribirlos y pues a más que
rico regalarle esos sentimientos tuyos y
quién tú eres en realidad tu esencia
estos seguidores a las personas
para leerlos
siento que hay que tener como una
grandeza porque está siendo totalmente
vulnerable bueno yo creo que te estoy
cayendo muy bien estamos en daño amigos
porque en realidad no me lo tanto pero a
mí me resulta mucho más sencillo
escribir que hablar te diré más jamás
esta entrevista podrá llegar al nivel de
cuando escriba un libro a la hora de
sabes de desnudarme porque no al final
es un proceso súper íntimo no y a mí de
te lo digo en serio me resulta más
sencillo escribir aunque no lo vaya a
publicar aunque sea para mí que contarle
mi problema a alguien creo que esto es
un error y por eso escribo tanto y tengo
tan pocos novios
los vídeos en youtube hablemos de socios
de youtube que yo estaba viendo
obviamente haciendo un investigación
previo a tener esta conversación
impresión muy chévere y que no estábamos
hablando también tener poesía con rock
como como cómo nació este me parece
maravilloso además pues mira nació
porque ya te digo me en españa es
habitual los recitales de poesía de
verdad y el pianito la guitarra acústica
y yo siempre sentía en plan de un poema
también puede ser nuestra lleno de rabia
puede estar lleno de fuerza también
porque no meterle aquí unas percusiones
nos tragamos una batería aún unos bajos
una guitarra eléctrica y tal cual cogí a
mis amigos porque al final yo trabajo
con mis amigos no y eso yo creo que eso
es una gran esencia que todo queda
grabado y hicimos una pieza de rock para
el niño que creció y crecer es una
trampa no creo que al final una trampa
también es tiene una vaina una esencia
muy rockera porque además es inhabitable
no que no caer no tienes más que crecer
crees que ya
o mejor dicho a plantear otra vez la
pregunta que no te he hecho pero la
plantea simple tan de mi cabeza hasta
dónde quieres crecer o qué
para ti qué es
claro yo no quería crecer sino si yo no
quería caer en la trampa pero te das
cuenta que por mucho que te resignes y
por mucho que no quieras tienes que caer
en la trampa así que lo mejor que puedes
hacer es saber que es una trampa y caer
todavía de la grandeza a lo mejor
bastante pues estás preparado no no
estoy preparado para nada prácticamente
no estoy preparado para el éxito no
estaba preparado para esta entrevista no
estoy preparado tampoco para el fracaso
no voy a la verdad no estoy preparado
son más won sabes lo que te quiero decir
entonces estoy voy viviendo voy cayendo
en la trampa
con encontrando pequeños motivos
ilusiones que evidentemente hacen falta
para seguir en este caso para mirar
literatura a cuántos hombres te falta
por besar hasta encontrar a ese mente
que realmente quieres porque pues
evidentemente creemos en el amor y todo
el mundo pues lo quiere o no quieres eso
si quiero es decir lo
mismo
pero también es una cosa cuando todos
nos quedamos mucho a nosotros mismos y
si seamos todo super egoísta ya no nos
vamos a quedar entre nosotros entonces
eso también es una gran movida no soy un
romántico soy un intenso y me gustaría
que me falta ser un hombre al que besar
pero estoy en crisis me encanta que
hables desde el amor porque también un
gran amor tuyo es tu abuela y
precisamente hay un libro sobre ella con
qué tan inspiradora es tu abuela para ti
a la hora de escribir acaba de crear
como te diría para mí mi abuela es
cuando cuando te eleva las bicicletas a
elliot cuando cuando gandhi va a recoger
a freud del día cuando que decirte para
mí mi abuela es una guía eso me ha
criado indirectamente también ha creado
mi abuela con todo lo que ello conlleva
y un momento cuando el día que me habló
de su testamento para ser concretos que
me dijo oye que voy a hacer esto
entonces me asusté de verdad porque
nunca había pensado seriamente la muerte
de mi abuela porque para mí era mi madre
y mi padre
era muy pronto yo sentía yo dije que
como que testamento no no no entonces yo
dije bueno cuéntame tu vida porque ya lo
había hecho en algunas ocasiones no me
parece que haya cosas muy interesantes
no porque necesito necesito que cuando
tú no estés hay algo que quede para
siempre y va a ser un libro
crisis cuáles son tus planes a futuro
escribir
y planear lo menos posible porque me he
dado cuenta que cuanto más planeas peor
porque no suele suceder y sí que hay que
enfocar en sí y sí que hay que
identificar fijar una mente ponerse
límites porque a final yo creo que lo
que te hace más libre es ponerte límites
pero no te hecho vale entonces mis
planes de futuro es seguir escribiendo y
no dejar jamás de disfrutar de las cosas
que me gustan que es lo que más me
gusta así pues de las cosas que más me
gustan desde luego de escribir que eso
por esto es de hablo no es peligroso
convertir una vocación en tu trabajo
claro yo creo que sí yo creo que es
hacer una especie de funambulismo en una
cuerda pero mantendrá el equilibrio voy
a intentarlo podemos ver más poesía o a
lo mejor una novela te quepa la menor
duda de que verás ambas cosas porque ya
te digo para mí son dos idiomas
completamente diferentes pero con los
que yo me manejo como la gente que es
que tiene doble nacionalidad no necesito
ambos géneros para expresar mental
literatura pues crisis yo te voy a pedir
que nos leas por favor por supuesto este
fragmento de los hombres a los que desee
bueno si quieres me encantaría porque
además es el poema homónimo que se llama
también hombres a los que se iba con
retranca para que veáis que la poesía
también puede ser otra cosa vamos a ver
mi primer novio fue un cabrón de esos de
braguetas suelta cuando me daba la
vuelta y un pequeño corazón el día que
pidió perdón no me lo pensé dos veces
cansado de estupideces le bajé los
pantalones y con segundas intenciones
dije jorge a ver si creces
a ver si quieres y jorge creció no
creció no mucho
13 sigue siendo
bueno de eso se trata como existe
también caer un poco en la trampa no
pero no tanto una cosa es mantener el
niño y otra cosa ser un adolescente toda
tu vida de ojo bueno sabes yo creo que
prefiero hacer un niño grande si un
adolescente toda la vida nuevamente
porque la gente se cree con esto de iu
no es que tienes que mantener al niño
pero el niño no es el el estúpido que
eras con 16 años el niño era se quieras
con otro ojo pones cristian de verdad ha
sido un placer lamentablemente se me
acaba el tiempo podemos quedar aquí
hablando cinco horas falta el tinto como
dicen aquí en colombia además tu primera
vez acá en colombia bienvenido esperemos
que la paz es increíble y bueno bien
viaje buen viaje de vuelta crisis
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa no gracias raúl y quiero
decir gracias también a todo el equipo
que estés aquí detrás de las cámaras que
sois una gente muy maja y increíble y
sobre todo lo vuelvo a repetir porque no
es fácil porque parece un nicho pequeño
pero la poesía está preparada para las
personas igual que la música pero es más
fácil encontrar radios y canciones que
un poema que te dé a ti lean poesía y
sobre todo gracias por dar espacio